all right time for another very
interesting and always engaging Tik Tok
reaction and today to switch things up
we'll be reacting to uh Tik toks of male
feminists you know when uh my producer
McKenna suggested that we do male
feminist Tik toks I said I'm pretty sure
we've done this before and she said we
haven't and I said no we've done like
actually 50 times I think we've done it
probably 50 to 100 times we've probably
done it but I was told we've never we've
actually never done it before in history
so we're going to uh react and I'll tell
you here's the thing just a little bit
of just to tell you how I'm feeling and
I they're kind of cutting all this out
that I'm saying right now anyway but
doing it doing the reaction videos is
demoralizing and I'll tell you why it's
demoralizing not just because it's cheap
content but really because we watch a
Tik Tok I'll try to say something about
it try to find something to say about it
but there are a lot of YouTube channels
where they do these reaction videos It's
All the Rage I've SP for a long time and
they get millions and millions of views
and they don't say anything it's like
the most popular reaction videos are the
ones where that someone watches
something and then they
go wow and that's it and that and then
and then they get 50 million views just
based on that alone awkward so it's like
if you try to actually say something
interesting so to to put some kind so
there's like some kind of substance to
the content uh you get penalized tell me
an opinion that you have about something
that's how I feel about reaction videos
so let's get into this reaction video
this first one is a a male feminist
talking about whether or not men should
be thanked or not let's watch so tell me
when you realize that the bar is way too
low it was less of a single event and
more of a gradual realizing of just how
my gender is I don't know if I've ever
been thanked for stopping when someone
says no during sex but I've definitely
been thanked for not guilt tripping
someone about it being told that someone
trusted me to get their female friend
home when she was too drunk the frankly
upsetting amount of times that I've been
thanked just for wearing a condom
one the final one is when I've been told
that I'm not really a guy because I'm
just
too
wow let's watch the next one today we
are fighting sexism by giving away some
free tampons would you like some free
tampons to fight
sexism would you two like some free
sexism would you like some free tampons
to fight sexism
uh
okay women can physically only produce
one baby a year whereas a man can get an
indefinite amount of women pregnant in a
year so why is it all the pressure on
birth control is on women when the issue
obviously lies with
men
jeez men protect women for
what for what tigers lions wild animals
dinosaurs from what you all have the
stupid conception that men protect women
men whose job is to protect could not
protect children a couple days ago
regardless let's get back to the
question from what are there men so you
agree men are dangerous like at least
some of them are dangerous right because
I can already hear some idiots screeing
Not all men but how are we supposed to
know exactly which men how do you this
without putting yourself in danger which
men are dangerous because for all we
know there are so many men out there who
are playing nice to get what they want
but when they can't they're abusive
pieces
of so we are going to play around the
idea that men protect women because you
have some ego trip or some but we are
going to dismiss the fact that men are
the ones who are harming women how about
instead of preaching men protect women
we teach men not to harm women and
children but no that doesn't work right
because you want women and children to
be vulnerable so that you can step in
and lure them into your safety instead
of dismantling the social norms and
patriarchal constructs that are causing
harm to these people you want to tell
women that men are not dangerous while
you know full well men are dangerous y
old insults are such pieces
of I don't know about that not sure
about that one that guy's a little crazy
you just choose one of those out the
other ones you know Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollar's drop in dominance
objective and irreversible as Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa
formerly agreed to use local currencies
in trade instead of the US dollar as
demand for the dollar weakens the buying
power of the dollar weekends this is why
Birch gold is busier than ever investors
and Savers are looking to harness the
power of physical gold held in a tax
sheltered IRA and you can too you can
protect your IRA of 401k by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold as a US dollar
continues to receive pressure from
foreign countries digital currency and
central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Walsh to
898988 plus braiding with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless festar reviews I
trust Birch gold to help you diversify
into gold if a central bank digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to depend on again
text Walsh to 98 98 98 if a girl wants a
guy who's older it's a preference if a
guy wants a girl who's younger it's
creepy I got a question for you Jimmy
why do you think some women prefer older
men real question usually a woman will
say that she prefers an older man
because she wants someone who is mature
emotionally intelligent confident
financially secure stable Etc now let me
ask you why do you think some men say
that they prefer younger women men who
prefer younger women can't talk to women
their own age want someone who they
think is more pure naive easier to
manipulate and usually has some weird
sexual attraction to youth reason why
there isn't a double standard is because
these aren't the same thing if a guy
were to say that he prefers older women
for their emotional intelligence and
maturity nobody would bat an eye now I
think all age preferences are stupid you
should treat people as individual and
talk to people in the same stage as life
as you the reason why one is weird and
the other isn't is because they aren't
the same thing and that is true for
literally every fake double standard you
pointed out okay I can't do this wrong I
I I
look the I I'm going to say one I'll say
one thing I'll say one more complete
thing about one of these videos and I'm
going to choose the one about men
protecting this is what the male
feminists don't understand okay you have
uh men have strength okay they have like
masculine energy they have a propensity
towards physical aggression much more
than women do it's especially the case
for younger men you know the younger man
is the more he's going to have that kind
of propensity and so you have a choice
place as a society okay do you want to
call men do you want to acknowledge
these differences in men and women and
do you want to acknowledge that men are
different than women and you can
acknowledge the fact that men you know
are sort of wired this way and women are
wired this way and then and then and
then you could call men to to take all
of that masculine energy and and use it
uh in service to something to something
good and service to to protecting the
people around them to protecting women
and children like you can call men to
that calling them some to something
higher something greater or you can do
what the male feminists do and uh and
you can determine that somehow calling
men to something greater is offensive or
or sexist and so instead what we should
do is we should pretend that these
differences don't exist that men don't
have that uh aggression they don't have
that energy they don't have that
strength or you can acknowledge they
have it and lecture them for for for
being wired that way and what does that
accomplish exactly what do that what
does that exactly
accomplish that was my one
speech we'll do one more
clip seven ah doc I'll break my arm you
got to help me oh my god get this man to
surgery hi um I have broken my arm oh my
God have
you can't help it feel it wouldn't have
broken if You' lost
weight
what
so that's been our reaction video don't
forget to like And subscribe see you
later
Champs